if the government Obama administration
did in fact spy on president Trump's
campaign one of the main targets may
have been Donald Trump jr. and he joins
us tonight dr. Geter thanks for coming
on what do you make of this good to be
with you Tucker how are you I'm great
but but confused so you have members of
Congress saying that this document which
I have not seen I don't think you have
either
changes the conversation completely but
they can't tell us what's in it so the
extent you have heard what's in it what
do you make of it you know it sounds
pretty troubling to me obviously this
has been a witch-hunt
probably the greatest since the Salem
witch trials the interesting thing about
it is the only collusion the only
shadiness the only thing that's been
discovered is what the prior
administration the DNC and all of them
have done the irony of all of this is if
Republicans conducted themselves the way
I've seen the Democrats conduct
themselves we'd be reading about this
and every page of every newspaper and
every TV channel in the world right now
we're a little bit more honourable than
them but it really sounds disturbing and
you know I don't know what to do it
because I don't know what's in it but if
all of these guys are saying people's
heads are gonna roll people are gonna
get fired and people may actually go to
jail I think the American people deserve
to know they've been led down a road to
believe X they've been sold a bill of
goods about us about our campaign from
18 months the media totally complicit in
helping the Dems do this and the only
thing we've discovered it was actually
them I think we need more information so
I think that the president has the
unilateral authority to declassify
documents do you think it would be a
good idea in this case I think it'd be a
phenomenal idea you know I'm not aware
of what that is I don't communicate with
him about these sort of thing right you
know but they've certainly gone after
him they've certainly gone after me our
whole family I took a 20-minute meeting
okay that everyone acknowledges would be
standard practice in the campaign I did
23 hours of testimony to put things into
perspective Hillary Clinton as Secretary
of State did 11 on Benghazi where people
died where she lied and said it was
about a video where we lost an
ambassador how are those things the same
but it's the double standard that the
American people are being fed again by
the Democrats
in total complicity with the media
that's why neither have any trust from
the American people anymore I believe in
fair we've been transparent throughout
this whole process it's disgusting well
certainly I think we'd all benefit from
seeing what's in this memo for sure do
you believe that your campaign was spied
on by agencies overseen by the Obama
White House during the campaign listen
what I've seen and what I've learned
over the last few months is bordering on
disgusting so there'd be little doubt in
my mind that it'd be possible but this
isn't the America that I thought would
happen I mean this is the stuff that you
read about from banana republics but it
seems like it's happening I'd like to
know I'm not privy to that information
but it seems like all of these
congressmen none of the Democrats even
want to read it they don't even want to
go see it
you know if it was the other way around
wouldn't there be a lot more outrage
from the media wouldn't they read about
it maybe once on CNN I think I would and
the fact that it's not being covered
they would rather recover that Donald
Trump had an extra scoop of ice cream
they would rather question a rear
admiral and a doctor appointed by the
Obama administration saying hey the guys
in phenomenal shape whether you like it
or not
they would rather question that as TV
quack doctors then actually talk about
these real issues that really affect
real Americans well why do you think
that Democrats in the Congress who said
for over a year that they're their only
aim is to get to the truth and to
understand the nexus between Russia and
the Trump campaign and the US government
why would they not want to see this memo
because they have no actual interest in
the truth Tucker what I've realized they
have interest in their sound bites and
the media will sell it they both went so
all in with this contrived Russia thing
based on the documents based on the
finest of the things that were probably
obtained pretty illegally they went all
in that they needed it to be true it
wasn't if it was true or what happened
they needed it to be true because their
entire narrative for 18 months their
entire credibility everything that
they've sold to the American people on
every TV channel for almost two years
has been based on the fact that this is
gospel that this is true and now it
turns out to all be nonsense and it was
actually them
prior administration doing some pretty
shady stuff I mean that is
earth-shattering that is disgusting and
the American people should be really
upset about it because this wasn't like
hey maybe we should get to the bottom of
it this was this is what happened
there's no ifs ands or buts about it and
you better believe it because we're
gonna stick it and Ram it down your
throat for two years I just heard from a
member of Congress who's not a hothead
at all it's kind of a moderate guy who
said he saw this and it's shocking and
so maybe the White House will take your
advice and declassify we can all find
out what is then and I think that might
be a great education Don Trump jr.
thanks a lot for coming on I appreciate
it Thank You Tucker good to be with you